D
HOMICIDE.
ANITA: CHRISTINA COLEMAN, THANK
YOU FOR THAT LIFE UPDATE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, PAUL PELOSI IS
GOING TO MAKE A RECOVERY.
EVERYBODY CAN AGREE ON THAT.
THROUGHOUT THE DAY WE HAVE BEEN
TRACKING THE STORY.
IT SEEMS HOUR BY HOUR THERE IS
NEW INFORMATION COMING OUT, A
LOT OF IT CONFUSING.
IN CHRISTINA'S REPORT SHE
MENTIONED THE SUSPECT THANKED
TIES TO WRITING ABOUT QAnon
AND COVID CONSPIRACIES.
BUT WHEN HE LIVED IN BERKELEY HE
HAD TIES TO AN ADDRESS "SLOGANS
OF A DIFFERENT TYPE.
>> ANYONE TRYING TO CONNECT THIS
GUY TO A POLITICAL PARTY, WE
CAN'T DO THAT.
I THINK THE ONLY THING WE DO
KNOW IS THIS GUY WAS OBVIOUSLY
VERY TROUBLED.
MENTALLY UNSTABLE AS WE HEARD
FROM HIS EX-OR OR EX-GIRLFRIEND.
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO CHERRY PICK
WHAT HE POSTED ONLINE.
HE LIVED IN A HOUSE WITH A LOT
OF SLOGANS PEOPLE WOULD
ASSOCIATE WITH THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY OR LIBERALS.
YOU CANNOT CONNECT THIS GUY IN
ANY WAY TO A POLITICAL PARTY AND
I THINK IT'S RECKLESS TO DO SO.
ANITA: I THINK YOU ARE TALK
ABOUT BLACK LIVES MATTER
SLOGANS.
OR DEFUND THE POLICE.
DAVID, CONSIDER THAT THIS IS ONE
OF THE RICHEST MOST POWERFUL
COUPLES ON THE PLANET.
SO WHERE WAS THE SECURITY ALARM?
WHERE WERE -- WAS ANY SECURITY
IN PLACE?
I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOMETHING
FROM THE "L.A. TIMES" TALKING
ABOUT HOW THE REAR DOOR --
THAT'S HOW THE ASSAILANT GOT IN.
HE GOT IN THROUGH A REAR DOOR.
I CAN'T SEE THAT QUOTE AT THE
MOMENT HERE.
HERE WE GO.
IT SAYS WHEN POLICE ARRIVED AND
KNOCKED ON THE FRONT DOOR,
SOMEONE INSIDE OPENED THE DOOR,
OFFICERS SAW PAUL PELOSI AND
DEPAPE EACH WITH ONE HAND ON A
SINGLE HAMMER.
SCOTT CONFIRMED DEPAPE FORCED
ENTRY INTO A REAR DOOR OF THE
PELOSI HOME.
SCOTT IS THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE CHIEF.
SO THE SUSPECT ACCESSED THE REAR
DOOR OF THE HOUSE.
THERE IS NO SECURITY.
WHERE ARE THE CAMERAS.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE BROKEN GLASS?
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
WHEN POLICE CAME TO THE DOOR,
SOMEONE ELSE OPENED THE DOOR?
WHO OPENED THE DOOR?
DAVID  * REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT WHO, WHAT, WHEN,
WHY AND HOW?
IF WE DID A WIDE SHOT ON THE
HOUSE, THERE ARE HIGH RESOLUTION
CAMERAS ON EVERY CORNER OF THAT
HOUSE, THAT'S EASY TO SEE.
THE GLASS APPEARS TO BE BROKEN
OUTWARD.
THAT'S ANOTHER QUESTION THAT
NEEDS TO BE ANSWERED.
POLICE OFFICERS TYPICALLY HAVE
THEIR BODY CAMERAS ON,
ESPECIALLY WHEN ENTERING A HOUSE
LIKE THIS.
WHERE IS THE BODY CAM VIDEO.
WHO OPENED DOOR IS SOMEONE
INVESTIGATORS NEED TO TALK TO.
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE AND
CAPITOL HILL THIS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL, THESE ARE THINGS THAT
DEMAND TRANSPARENCY IN THE
REPORTING.
AN ASSAULT ON POTENTIALLY A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS' PROPERTY, ON
HER HUSBAND, IT DOESN'T ADD UP.
TO LARA'S POINT, TRYING TO
ASSIGN THIS TO ONE OR THE OTHER,
ANYONE WHO DOES THAT IS NOT A
GOOD JOURNALIST OR A GOOD
PUNDIT.
ANITA: THERE ARE SO MANY
QUESTIONS.
DAVID  * SHOW ME THE AUDIO.
IF THERE WAS A BODY CAM WHEN THE
POLICE CAME ON, THAT AUDIO WOULD
EXIST.
ANITA DESPITE ALL THESE
QUESTIONS, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
RUSHING TO TRY TO CONNECT ALL OF
THIS TO JANUARY 6.
>> THE THING THAT'S PROBABLY THE
MOST HAUNTING ABOUT WHEN WE HEAR
THE REPORTS OF THE ASSAILANT, OF
THE ATTACKER WE WERE SPEAKING
OF.
HE WAS YELLING OUT THE THINGS
THAT WE HEARD DURING JANUARY 6,
WHICH IS WHERE IS NANCY?
WE NEED TO END THIS TYPE OF
RHETORIC.
IT NEEDS TO STOP.
AND IT IS INCREDIBLY, INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS.
ANITA: THE NEWS SOURCE "AXIOS"
PUT UP THIS QUOTE SAYING A
SOURCE BRIEFED ON THE
INVESTIGATION TELLS ME PAUL
PELOSI'S ATTACKER HAD A BAG
CONTAINING ZIP-TIES IN A
DISTURBING ECHO OF JANUARY 6.
IT CAN BE USED TO IMMOBILIZE A
VICTIM, AND ADD TO THE MENACING
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING THE
HOME INVASION.
WHY IS THERE THIS RUSH TO TIE
THIS TO JANUARY 6?
LARA  *.
THERE ARE FOLKS OUT THERE
DESPERATE TO TRY AND HELP THEM
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR FACTS TO
COME OUT.
THEY ARE RUSHING IN.
JOEY, YOU SAID THIS YESTERDAY ON
THE SHOW.
FOR ANYONE TO TRY AND USE THIS
FOR A POLITICAL MOTIVE IN ANY
WAY, AND THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO HARKEN BACK
TO JANUARY 6.
THERE IS NOTHING TO TIE ANY OF
THIS TO JANUARY 6.
POTENTIALLY THIS GUY WAS
SCREAMING, WHERE'S NANCY, THAT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH ANYTHING.
ANITA: DO YOU THINK THIS IS A
RUSH TO JUDGMENT FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
JOEY: THE PERSON WHO WOULD HAVE
ME BELIEVE GAS PRICES ARE
CHEAPER NOW THAN THEY WERE AT
WHATEVER THE HIGH WAS YESTERDAY
ABOUT GOES PRICES BEING AS $5
WHEN BIDEN TOOK OFFICE WHEN THEY
WERE $2.30.
THE PERSON WHO WOULD LIE TO MY
FACE AND TELL ME THAT, SHE CAN
SAY WAR SHE WANTS TO.
LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR RISES
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO SEE WHERE
AMERICANS ARE ON THIS WHITE
HOUSE'S ABILITY TO SELL YOU A
LIE.
I A LOT MORE QUESTIONS THAN
ANSWERS.
I'M NOT A POLITICAL OPERATIVE
SPINNING A NARRATIVE.
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD CALM DOWN
AND SEE WHAT THE FACTS ARE.
I WISH EVERYBODY WHO GOT THEIR
HOME BROKEN INTO AND WERE NEARLY
BEATEN TO DEATH RECEIVED THIS
KIND OF LOOK.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, IF YOU
BREAK INTO MY HOME AND TRY TO
KILL ME, I WILL KILL YOU FIRST.
I LIVE IN A STATE THAT ALLOWS ME
TO PROTECT MYSELF.
ANYONE OUT THERE SHOULD EDUCATE
THEMSELVES THE SAME WAY.
WAY.
LARA:THE ONLY THING THAT WAS
HIGHLIGHTED